[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt der
murat hat sich schon seit längerem eine
neujahrsbrezel gewünscht und da habe ich
mir gedacht mach ich doch gleich ein
video für euch heute geht es der
neujahrsbrezeln in vielen orten ist es
verbraucht dass man am neujahrsmorgen
eine neujahrsbrezel oder zum beispiel
diese kleinen schweinchen backte andere
formen und die daneben auch verschenkt
oder gemeinsam verzehrt und die brezel
oder das gepäck soll dann im neuen jahr
vor unheil schützen vor krankheiten soll
einfach glück bringen gesundheit und ich
denke es ist einfach eine richtig schöne
geste
falls ja neujahrsmorgen also lust und
zeit diese zu backen
dann könnt ihr das gerne nach meinung
zählt machen bei mir gibt es dazu noch
eine winter marmalade ich bin jetzt mit
vagen glücks marmelade
die könnt ihr nämlich auch in zu kleinen
gläschen verpacken und auch richtig
schön verschenken
da könnte etwas kleines rüstet drauf
schreiben und dann finde ich ist es
nachts nicht richtig schön ist ich mach
den hefeteig
jetzt sag ich mal eben die zutaten die
für den hefeteig brauche für den
hefeteig verwende ich einen würfel hefe
80 gramm zucker 2 esslöffel warmes
wasser etwas vanille extrakt 2 500 gramm
mehl 250 milliliter buttermilch einen
teelöffel salz und 120 gramm butter
ich gebe zuerst die hefe in eine rutsche
sie da kommt dann der zucker dazu und
das wasser und ich kann die zutaten
verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier einfach noch die
übrigen zutaten rein und dann knetet den
teig für etwa zehn minuten zu einem
schönen weichen und geschmeidigen teig
und ihr könnt den teig entweder mit der
hand verkneten
oder einfach in der küchenmaschine und
ich mache das gerne hier weil es einfach
schneller geht und ich lerne frei habe
zu schützen zum beispiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das land warum
ich mache zeigt versteckens zwecke
stanley vertrag fertig und ich habe noch
zwei esslöffel mehl dazu gegeben also
wenn ihr merkt dass der hefeteig ein
bisschen zu weich es gibt dem
behinderten wenn ihr merkt erst zu
festen gibt einfach noch frisch hat
jetzt nämlich den teig raus und formen
zu machen und dann lasse ich ihn in der
schüssel abgedeckt für eine stunde ruhen
und kann ihm der zwischenzeit schon mal
die marmelade
[Musik]
für die marmelade verwende ich äpfel und
orangen insgesamt eineinhalb kilo 100
gramm an rohmasse ein bisschen
tonkabohne eine prise zimt und 500 gramm
gelierzucker das ist der drei plus eins
zucker ich mach dir mal ballade jetzt
mit einem schild zucker das ist der drei
plus eins zucker den mag ich ganz gerne
weil die marmelade dann nicht zu fuß
wird
und wenn ihr jetzt 1 214 zu gehabt dann
müsste zwei teile früchte 1 tl zucker
nehmen schaut da einfach auf die
verpackung und ich schau jetzt einfach
dass das geschälte und geschnittene
gewicht 1500 gramm sind in dem jetzt
einfach überraschen und äpfel
die orangen filetieren die ft
schweinfurt erkennen müssen
[Musik]
und zum filetieren dann einfach die
orange in die hand nehmen und die filets
rechts und links von dieser orangenhaut
wegschneiden von diesen trennwänden
[Musik]
den rest drücke ich dann noch aus dann
habe ich auch noch den ganzen
orangensaft
[Musik]
ich gebe mich heute gewürze rhein etwas
zimt tonkabohne habe ich bereits gegeben
dann dem gelierzucker und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr die marmelade noch
aromatisieren mit marzipan zum beispiel
aber im prinzip könnte ich jetzt auch
alles zu geben was wir gerne haben
sternanis ziemlich nelken piment karton
da könnte die winterliche marmelade so
machen wir es ihr euch am besten
schmeckt und ich lasse jetzt die
marmelade hier in der kenwood kochen ihr
könnt es aber auch ganz normal im
kochtopf machen einfach auf dem herd zu
bereiten und meistens steht ja auch
schon auf der verpackung wie lange man
sieht man mal lade kochen muss bei mir
sind sie zwei minuten und dann mache ich
gleich noch die shell ihr probe
[Musik]
jetzt ist die marmelade fertig und ich
habe hier bereits gelee probe gemacht
das heißt ich gebe immer so ein bisschen
was auf dem teller und schaut dann aufs
fest wird und jetzt könnt ihr die
marmelade entweder so stich lassen oder
einfach pürieren und ich werde jetzt
pürieren und dann gelder umfüllen
[Applaus]
jetzt will ich die marmelade einfach in
einmachgläser habe ich vorher
ausgedruckt und dann verschließe ich sie
und dann kann man die neujahrsbrezel
formen
[Musik]
der teig ist schön aufgegangen jetzt
wird die brezel der form und ich nehme
jetzt einfach so etwa vierte vom teig
weg damit mache ich später den job damit
mache ich später den zopf und den rest
vor mich jetzt zu einem langen schönen
streich ich habe es mir anders überlegt
nehmen drittel weg damit ich mehr habt
zum schlechten
[Musik]
und den strang habe ich jetzt so geformt
dass die enten ein bisschen dünner sind
und in der mitte teils ability kann
nämlich eine back folie
da kommt ein bisschen back transportraum
dann kommt da direkter strang drauf und
wird zu einer break viel geformt und
zwar und ein großer bogen dann oben
einmal wirbel
dann dienten hier drunter stecken dann
habt ihr schon mal das grundgerüst werde
jetzt kurz zur seite und nehme jetzt den
übrigen teig und den teile ich jetzt
gleichmäßig im drei portionen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann daraus drei strenge formen
es geht am besten wenn man so ein
bisschen back transport einfach immer
auf der arbeitsplatte hat komisch aber
dann hafte zeit ein bisschen
[Musik]
jetzt einen schönen job formen sowie bei
den haaren von außen nach innen und ich
fange jetzt mit ich an und macht dann
die andere seite von der anderen seite
nach unten hin darf der zopf wird auch
gerne etwas dünner werden
[Musik]
jetzt vorsichtig den zopf direkt hier
unten auf die brezel legen
jetzt denke ich den hier nochmal schön
ab wo lasse noch mal etwa eine halbe
stunde auf
spritzig die brezel schön aufgegangen
und ich kann selbst mit eigelb
bestreichen
das habe ich vorher mit etwas wasser
vermischt jetzt ganz vorsichtig darüber
[Musik]
so bekommst eine schöne farbe und auch
einen schönen glanz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich komme jetzt noch ein bisschen hg
zucker drauf
[Musik]
dann kann die brezen schon gebacken
werden
[Musik]
murat darf jetzt probieren du hast du ja
die brezel gewünscht du hast steht der
gewinn stoff sondern das projekt immer
er kann nicht das finde ich schön ist
doch noch gerecht
kennt ihr und zwar neujahrsbrezel sind
süß zwischen ein bisserl ungleich
aufgegangen hat also ich muss aber auch
sagen ich hab auch neuer spreads
hingegen jemand normal
eine normale presse nur größer ich finde
es schön wunderschön
ich habe extra dance of da drauf gemacht
ja nein vielleicht macht er beim zopf
einfach ein viertel vom teig gemischt
das einfach ok probleme und du bekommst
von der marmelade damit der moral ruhig
ins neue jahr startet mit blitzschlag
zukunft wagen
ich hab einfach nicht auf dich hab' die
andere ich geb dir harmonie okay das ist
dan fehlen uns mal wenn ihr wenn ihr
jetzt supermarkt geht in so etwas erholt
dann holt euch wirklich den hagel zu
kommen das schlägt sich dann lässig ich
bin ja der schmeckt gibt es andere der
hagelzug es soweit nach harmonie und
wissmann wir sind eher harmonisch
miteinander wieder weil ich liebe was
ich mir sein partner die musiker das
will ich nicht kann man das wieder
rückgängig machen blieben die letzten
zehn jahre
das management hier los wurde des
schülers werde ich gerne rückgängig
machen standen respektieren schmidt ich
kanns ja ich hab die marmelade
jetzt hat mein herz und meine marmelade
gehälter trägt abzüge orangenmarmelade
aber ich finde man kann mehrmals zu
handeln weil man schmeckt man ja erst
gar nicht macht es wieder auch nach und
nimmt diesen hagelzüge es gut und ich
meine wenn man die matte nicht machen
würde kann man das ganze auch mit ganz
normaler marmelade ist aber wir kommen
an tradition noch mal das ist vielerorts
ganz unterschiedlich also ich habe auch
gelesen dass bei vielen das gepäck was
übrig blieb und hart wurde dann an die
sich nutztiere verfüttert wurde
damit die eben auch vor krankheit
geschützt sind und manche haben das
sogar zerbröselt und dann noch mit den
samen in die erde damit das schön wächst
bis jetzt mit 40 nein das ist ja noch
frisch aber sicher aus wie ein nutztier
aber vielleicht wächst ja noch irgendwie
machen sie auf jeden fall nach und wenn
jetzt nach macht dann nehmt diesen
hashtag auf jeden fall damit sich eure
neujahrsbrezel aussehen jedoch hashtag
nutzt hier ja und ob überhaupt ein
schönes neues jahr genau richtig schön
ist er durch coole vorsätze und der
beste browser ist einfach ein besserer
mensch zu werden
doch besser ja ich bin auch ich bin der
mensch nutzt ihr also macht's gut
[Musik]